what up space fam golden here from anime
outpro and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story in
this one we get monkey god Luffy we get
kaido's final awakened form kaido
flashback a death and more so make sure
to stay tuned for this one if you do
enjoy these one piece videos and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
Channel power came with it and smash
that like button with no mercy remember
smashing is pirate king energy and
passing his character energy and no one
wants to be Orochi especially in this
chapter if you haven't made this video
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now without further Ado let's jump
into It spoilers and all this chapter is
called 20 years referring to the
prophecy and as we'll see we get a
significant flashback to the events of
20 years before but more on that later
the chapter starts where we left off
last time with Luffy's giant arm
towering over kaido's Dragon form mom
was freaking out since Luffy asked him
to move onigashima out of the way and
he's still doubting whether he can
actually do so he even says that it
can't be done but even as he's saying
this he recalls his mom's words and
trusts in him and being able to revive
the kozuki clan in the future then he
begins headbutting the island probably
knocking some sense back into himself
but maybe this is also just him trying
everything he can to move the island we
get some great panels of Luffy and kaido
in the chapter the juxtaposition between
the two Is frequent and at first we see
Luffy facing downwards and kaido facing
upwards and kaido never ceases to
impress as an antagonist for a while now
it was hinted at or remarked that he's
getting exhausted I'm pretty sure even
Yamato noticed a while ago and she would
know but the dude is as confident as
ever Oda is really doing Justice to how
hard it is to beat this yonko I don't
think anyone will feel like Luffy's
eventual Victory wasn't earned because
of the amount of time and respect odape
the kaido over the course of this war
after everything he's already been
through including Luffy punching him
through his face literally through it he
says he'll take this massive attack from
Luffy head-on remember he dodged one of
zoro's attacks before and yet he is now
after after all that fighting gonna take
on what looks like Luffy's ultimate
attack to date you gotta respect the
dude kaido then says this country's hero
burned to death 20 years ago referring
to Odin crazy how much respect kaido
still has for Odin after all this time
even considering him this country's one
and only hero he then uses a new move
flaming Drum dragon AKA great blazing
Dragon torch where he pretty much
becomes a fire dragon not only is he
blowing fire anymore his whole body is
surrounded with it now there's been no
mention of this being his Awakening and
you guys know I think his Awakening was
from Magikarp to a dragon but we can say
that this is a further Awakening of
powers a new and perhaps final move he's
been saving for this moment this dude is
still surprising us and has been holding
stuff back absolutely amazing stuff even
though Luffy seemed overpowered right
after his Awakening was revealed Oda has
done a great job of letting kaido
maintain his dignity and he has stood
his ground against this awakened God
fruit for a while now despite it being
the most ridiculous fruit ever now he
even gives us something brand new with
flaming Drum dragon and I absolutely
can't wait to see the clashes of these
two seemingly ultimate Godly mythical
Zone attacks kaido further comments that
they meaning the people of wano have
waited for you saviors to show up
meaning Luffy and his friends as kaido's
dragon body continues to light up on
fire Luffy's hand gets burned and he has
to let go of kaido kaido even reassures
him saying don't worry it's okay to let
go I assure you I won't run and I love
this attitude from the antagonist he's
seen a stronger version of Luffy than
we've ever seen before and he's not even
worried enough to try to dodge his
ultimate attack he'll even help Luffy by
promising not to run away it's
definitely arrogance but he probably
thinks he can break Luffy's spirit and
make the fight finish sooner if he can
take such a big attack and survive it
like it was nothing kaido even assures
Luffy they'll actually do more than
survive it he'll vaporize Luffy's attack
and maybe even Luffy in the process and
he seems to be speaking the truth as a
horn on the giant skull immediately
melts when it comes into contact with
kaido's body Luffy is confident too
though and pretty much says he won't let
that happen he thinks back to his
learning Ryo here in wano and says
thanks to Graham's kyogoro he can attack
without making contact I really like
that touch again it's emphasizing the
power and importance of hockey even with
Luffy's a ridiculously broken fruit he
wouldn't have been able to touch kaido's
Burning Body without druyo but now that
he learned how to use it he can still
beat him without needing to touch him I
said last chapter that hockey would play
a big role in his final attack and
that's exactly what we're seeing here he
needs to show kaido he's a master of
hockey and not just someone who got
lucky with his fruit before he defeats
the yonko Luffy with a smile on his face
says he'll knock kaido to the bottom of
hell you'd love to see it I guess that
would make him zoro's underlings and
Zoro is the king of Hell after all the
two attacks are finally Unleashed on
each other blazing bagua verses and this
is big Luffy's I have no idea how to
pronounce this but bajrang gun we're
told this is a reference to the Hindu
monkey God who was potentially an
inspiration for sunbukong the kanji used
even means Monkey King and that's so
cool after all the theories that Luffy
might have the Sun Wukong monkey god
fruit Oda gives us this moment where he
launches a monkey god attack he really
gave us monkey god Luffy even if he did
end up having a different no less hype
mythical Zone fruit and I love Oda for
it he's really delivered in this Arc
giving us everything we wanted and more
unfortunately we don't get to see the
result of the Clash right away just that
Luffy is using his other arm to block
his face and he seems in pain might be
the pressure from the impact as well as
kaido's burning heat spreading from him
we then jump to other events like usop
doing his best to save a dropped kinemon
and Kiku we see other soldiers saying
they're counting on Straw Hat to take
kaido down for good kawamatsu comments
that this nightmare won't end unless
titles driven from the land and the
flashback reaffirmed that that really is
the case we jump back in time to the
scabbards running from a boiling Odin
during the day of his execution the shot
goes off that finished him and I'd
assume there'd be some hockey infused
bullets coming from the gun or something
since it would be kind of anticlimactic
for a normal gun to finish off Odin
after everything he's been through in
that case even a little kid could have
fired it off and killed Odin so that's
just something I've been wondering about
we then see more of the Annoying Orochi
being Orochi and remember if you want to
not be like him just make sure you've
made the like button explode with
fireworks as it does now when pressed
Orochi tells him they'd only go to kuri
and kaido decides he'll deal with Odin's
son himself we see kaido smashing
through people as they beg him to have
mercy and to stop hunting the kozuki
clan while Orochi commands the forces to
shoot any Vermin who would defy their
Shogun Orochi since they saw no one else
fleeing the ruins of the castle they
assume that the kozuki line is
officially dead then oroshi makes the
diamond true sides whether they'll help
them usher in a new wano or wage war the
daimyo obviously refused to work with
them even saying the answer is obvious
they try to avenge Odin including the
Zorro look alike but as we know they
don't manage to stop kaido kaido Burns
countless people with his breath as
Orochi lasts or what she calls the
others weaklings even though the dude is
completely reliant on kaido himself
crazy what happens to a person when he
doesn't smash that like button and then
we see time pass we see able-bodied men
being recruited to work in factories we
see people being kidnapped we see the
pollution of the environment making the
place unlivable for the majority of
people the water becomes undrinkable the
crops stop growing you see skulls just
hanging around on the ground all the
while they try to break the spirits of
the workers by saying that one will stay
closed and they shouldn't count on
miracles to save them however some still
speak of patience in toki's words it's
like the prisoners who Survive by
believing in the legend of the sun god
Nika the warrior of Liberation then
Orochi keeps being hateable laughing at
the poor people who ate the leftovers of
defective smile fruits and began to
laugh ceaselessly he was amused at how
hungry and with their loved ones Keeling
over around them they'll still never be
able to stop laughing he calls it the
perfect faith for the country's pests
and laughs this must be the most
hateable character in one piece honestly
tell me if you think of a more hateable
one but I really can't now we jump back
to the present with an on fire Orochi
trying to take kyori down with him but
luckily dendro comes in time and saves
her props to those who predicted it
would be dangerous in the comments of
the last video I know there were some of
you you were correct and hopefully we've
finally seen the end of Orochi the dude
who just hasn't been able to stay dead
in the past thanks to his own mythical
Zone fruit I'm telling you these
mythical Zone fruits are crazy and if
you want to learn more about them check
out my all mythical zones and their
powers explained Link in the description
back to the chapter though and it seems
like this is really it for rochi finally
since we see one of the flying wish
lanterns with the writing please make
Orochi disappear that to me suggests
that tenja did in fact make the wish
come true this time because otherwise
why show it together we see another one
saying free us from hell and then we
jump to Luffy and kaido's Clash again
they are both still going with a
determined look on their faces this of
course suggests that like denjudo made
the first wish come true Luffy is about
to make the second one come true by
defeating kaido and thus freeing the
people of wano from hell and they never
would have been in the position they're
in if not for kaido it's also just crazy
to see how far the conquerors hockey is
shooting off from the original point of
impact but yeah that's what happened in
this one let me know who was your MVP
what will happen next is this attack
going to win it for Luffy or will kaido
keep the fight going a while longer
we're told by the narrator that the
present hears the cries of the past and
I wonder if that's foreshadowing that
we'll be jumping into a flashback in the
next chapter and get some more kind of
backstory of how he decided to go from
the maybe I'm Joy boy guy to the I'm
going to ruin wano's whole career guy if
we jump right into a flashback next
chapter then this could very well be the
last attack I am not one to believe that
Luffy will lose another time to kaido
but time will tell and let me know if
you think that the raid will fail or at
least the title will beat Luffy one more
time anyways if you did enjoy this video
then you know what to do trailer parking
with it and smash that like button don't
be like a passing Orochi but be a
smashing pirate king if you haven't make
this video you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates after Luffy
beats kaido I strongly believe Luffy
will be a yonko and you can check out my
new video the next generation of yonko
is already here to learn more about that
and the other new yonko in addition to
Luffy also you can check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that also
includes videos on all the yonko
Warlords Admirals mythical zones and
much more link to that is in the
description thanks again for your
support and until next time see us Space
Cowboys